if you were put under cryogenic sleep
due to a deadly global disease what
would you do you've just woken up in an
empty laboratory with monsters lurking
right outside no one is coming to save
you i'm going to break down the mistakes
made what you should do and how to beat
the thorn monsters in king of thorne
ninety percent of the world is going to
die and the planet is just skipping
along going about its day when people
suddenly see a mysterious object
descending from the heavens it's not a
bird not a plane and it's not superman
but a woman crashing down and
splattering like an egg on the sidewalk
but her death is not normal as soon as
she hit the ground her body turned to
stone crumbling upon impact with her
petrified corpse just laying there for
all to see hmm her dying during the
holidays makes me think that she was on
the naughty list and her turning into
some kind of stone makes me suspect that
she was infected with some kind of crazy
disease now if we talk about the worst
of the worst diseases out there that can
actually kill you within 24 hours of
infection this can range from ebola to
the bubonic plague to dengue fever and a
meningococcal disease which is a disease
that spreads saliva and nasal droplets
from infected people and can compromise
the lining of the brain and spinal cord
but this chick completely turned into
some kind of stone thing which means
that it likely could be an autoimmune
disease that can affect and show
problems on the skin such as the
autoimmune condition psoriasis this also
makes me think that anything that can
cause symptoms to show on the outside of
your skin is serious enough to make
anyone freak out cause that stone corpse
means that shit's about to go down and
we have no idea what's going on but if
you like the thought of pretending you
know what's going on but really don't
like our writer over here sorry then
this is where raycon will come in handy
and will also be our sponsor for today's
video thank you because just like
mutated viruses that don't stop killing
oh no these earbuds won't stop killing
the marketplace that's what i'm trying
to say they're the new everyday earbuds
that offer an improved rubber oil look
and feel they sound great they have a
low profile in my ear and they're secure
as hell i love it thanks to their
optimized gel tips for that perfect and
ear fit i love them for my workouts when
i'm doing my laundry they even got me
jam into stevie wonder on the daily so
push the doom and gloom of the world's
worst anime virus out of your ear and
make way for ray cons offered 8 hours of
playtime and 32 hour battery life with a
built-in mic that'll have your infected
screams and squeals sounding hd at the
press of a button that's so cool all the
while listening to the best of the best
at half the price of other premium audio
brands so support the channel and click
the link in the description box below or
go to buyrecon.com htba for up to 30 off
and a 45 day happiness guarantee what
more do you need brought to you by reiko
the public surrounds this woman's corpse
in shock as soon enough the world comes
to know the petrifying news the world
health organization has just announced
that the corpse of this woman was
carrying a deadly virus the world is
coming face to face with a global deadly
virus known as acquired cellular
induration syndrome or the medusa virus
which results in the body producing an
excess amount of chemical compounds
produced in lethal quantities that has a
100 mortality rate turning people within
the second stage of infection to stone
within 12 hours and there's no cure but
of course leave it to the russians like
this guy who then tells the world that
they figured out a way to beat the virus
by offering crowd preservations to
people whose bodies will then be frozen
until science can figure out a cure but
the nsa doesn't trust his company venus
gate the largest biotech company in the
world with infinite resources run by
doomsday cults and they think that they
created this virus so they put up a top
secret plan in place to find out the
truth a few years later the cryo chamber
becomes operational and 160 members from
around the world gather to be the first
of many to be cryogenically frozen as
the destroyed world waits for someone to
find a cure that will not come to most
of them as they will almost all die a
horrible death soon and here we meet the
twins kasumi and shizuku among others as
they drive in buses to this creepy
scottish castle inside at orientation
the group is told that they will soon be
put to sleep as their sleep pods and
vitals will be monitored by the most
advanced computer system in the world
named alice so even if the staff dies
the whole lab will still be running but
there's one problem only one of the
twins can enter the cryo chamber so they
sadly bid goodbye to each other
promising to meet up again whenever
kasumi wakes up dropping off their
belongings and being injected with a
tracker the 160 members head deep below
blissfully unaware of what horrors await
them as they lay in their coffins and
pass into a deep slumber
whoa even if the world was in shambles
i'd still be skeptical as hell about all
of this for one cryogenics are you
kidding me you mean to tell me that i'll
be frozen with my liberties taken away
from me and i'll be looked after by a
bunch of kooks you are insane for
starters cryobiologist kenneth b story
claims that cryonics is impossible and
will never be possible as it proposes
overturning the laws of physics
chemistry and molecular science which
leads me to my next point if you told me
that cryonics was invented then i
certainly waited at least a few decades
with ample research under its belt and
not a mere three or four years before
testing it out myself the problem with
cryopreserving as of now is that when
frozen significant fractions of the
water within the body are converted to
ice however they are not truly frozen
the chemistry is merely slowed down
which can only be sustained for a few
months if an individual was cooled to
temperatures required for true long-term
stability then as of current technology
the person frozen inside would not
survive so i say we might have to let it
go on this idea seemingly centuries
later kasumi finally wakes up but
something isn't right she puts on her
glasses and sees the most horrid sight
nothing no personal no lights no one
except thorny vines encasing the entire
room hugging the walls it's almost as if
she's been sleeping for decades but
that's when all the cryopods begin
opening up one by one and confused
members wake up to each other baffled
and worried something is not right and
everyone knows it kasumi tries to get
down but that's when she comes face to
face with a horrifying mutated bat
scaring the life out of her and causing
her to fall and that's when the horror
show begins one by one these mutated
devil bats begin to descend from the
skies above as an army of blood-sucking
vampires begin killing everybody in the
room in absolute terror people begin
panicking and rushing to the door
hitting and shoving each other like
their lives depend on it the door
finally opens but there's no lift and in
all the chaos and pushing and shoving
people begin falling to their deaths
seemingly choosing to avoid a more
terrifying fate by staying with the
mutated bats but down the shaft the
horror only continues with this gigantic
terrifying octopus eating all of those
who fall to their death like a 10 course
cannibal meal but then this glasses guy
finally finds a second door leading into
another strange room and so the crew
makes a terrified dash for the door
sealing themselves in to catch their
breath however they don't realize that
what awaits them outside of this room is
even more terrifying than the monsters
hear themselves
i knew nothing ever good came from
trusting a company with the word corp in
their name but i'm surprised kasumi even
got out of there without even a scratch
there wasn't any good way out of this
but we definitely could have used
everybody else to help me out during
their kerfluffle i would have run near
the elevator doors and would have tried
to stay within the crowd using them as
protection to decrease the likelihood of
the mutant bats picking me off but i
would have purposefully tried to stuff
myself within the middle of the crowd
toward either the left or right side of
the walls surrounding them this way even
if i got pushed to the front i would
have been stopped by the various
structures tethered to the wall and this
part is very important so listen up if
the power is not working properly i
would be scared to take a lift in a
normal building and these people want to
take a lift inside this power drained
laboratory that's insane this is why
being positioned near the left or right
side of the walls would have been the
perfect spot the crowd would have helped
me from avoiding any bats and on the off
chance there wasn't a lift there then at
least i would have been able to grab
onto the side of either of the walls
without being mindlessly shoved into the
empty lift shaft the group takes a
breather as we meet the other surviving
members they try to figure out how long
they've been asleep for and where those
terrifying bats came from just then
kasumi recognizes this guy's legs as it
was the same legs she saw earlier let's
call him six-pack stud and she thinks
something is not right with him and what
happened to the computer system alice
who was supposed to be looking after
them the group has more questions than
answers but decide to get a move on
exploring what's beyond this room as no
one's coming to help them just then they
hear a strange rumbling outside sounding
like the footsteps of something huge
they need to move now the group finally
stumbles across a path overridden with
leaking water they have to find another
route this old man has had enough and he
plops down and just sits there but then
in the distance we see saliva dripping
from the ceiling dripping closer to the
group as the seconds pass menacingly
approaching the old man and he doesn't
even know it tall guy gets annoyed with
old man's whining and tells him to shut
it but just then a flood of saliva
spills right in front of him as he looks
up to the most terrifying sight this
dragon saber-toothed creature the beast
then chomps down onto the old man's face
lifting him up with its alien mandibles
as the terrified old man helplessly begs
to be spared but this creature is no
ally and clamps down onto his neck
decapitating his head from his body and
the rest of the gang reacts in horror
they need to run and they bolt skirting
through the pipe-ridden hallways until
this kid tells them to stop running
claiming that this monster is exactly
like the one in his game this kid thinks
he knows that monster's weakness he
tells the group that the monster
attacked them because he heard them and
that it's actually blind the group
thinks he's nuts but they are running
out of time the monster is drawing
closer cornering their only exit forcing
them to think fast and jumping into the
water below them thanks to six-pack
studs creativity okay okay if the first
thing that you saw was mutant bats then
i think it's safe to assume that there
are probably more baddies lurking around
this facility especially if we've been
asleep long enough or plants to take
over the entire underground building now
the kid said that this monster had bad
vision meaning that it relied mainly on
echolocation but if that's true then
that would still have meant that that
monster could see at least a little a
very common mistake is thinking that
bats are blind when in reality they
actually have very good vision it's just
more sensitive than regular humans and
some just can't see color however if we
used what the kid said then that means
that this monster mainly uses
echolocation to find us which is done by
emitting high frequency sound pulses
through the mouth or nose and listening
to the echo and the only things in
nature that are made of flat smooth
surfaces are bodies of water and rocks
however anything made from materials
with small ridges or imperfections like
old metal pipes would likely bounce the
sound back to the bat giving them a
specific location of where this material
was located which is why i think the
group could have hid behind the
countless metal pipes there and could
have shielded themselves from the
monster's echo location as it would have
bounced back on the pipes instead of
them and we were near a body of water to
jump in which is why i think it could
have been worth risking it before simply
jumping into the water not knowing the
direction of where this indoor river
would take us kosumi tries but fails to
catch her breath in the water and she
passes out and the gang unknowingly
leaves her behind until they realize
she's missing and six-pack stud heads
back in to save her barely making it in
time to save her and he brings her back
to shore but something is off because
tall guy here thinks that there's more
of those monsters down in this hallway
he's wrong however since the terrifying
monsters are right above them dripping
saliva onto the cold steel floor the
group looks up and sees an army of those
things ready to pounce causing them to
run six-pack stud thinks fast and trips
some of them as the gang blasts through
the hallway at mach speed running under
this door as they come to a dead end the
gang now has no choice but to fight
these things six-pack stud gets ready to
bring it on but not before tall guy and
glasses guy decide to shoot their
borrowed lead into these beasts blasting
all of them six ways to sunday but the
horror won't stop as more of these
monsters keep coming and one of them
eyes six-pack stud and tries coming for
his face he demands that one of them
pass him a gun as he gets cornered but
then suddenly kasumi distracts them by
banging a wrench causing the monsters to
come for her throat she's about to die
as the monsters get ready to pounce but
then six-pack stud gets awarded a
shotgun and takes this final monster
down blowing him away better than simon
pegg in an action flick but suddenly one
of the monsters pops back up using its
tail and knocking down tall guy forcing
six-pack stud to chase him away before
shooting the door shut this monster is
not what it seems as its corpse suddenly
turns into stone this thing has the
medusa virus and now it seems as though
it's evolved to infect animals too the
group contemplates how long they've
truly been asleep for as they try to
take a breather and this nurse bandages
up tall guy telling him that she was a
medical professional six-pack stud also
loads up while kasumi and glasses guy
dig through the files to find out what
has happened but can't find much
although something is not sitting right
with six-pack stud as he notices
something about glasses guy just then
this blonde-haired girl finally snaps
thanks to the kid not shutting up about
his game freaking out about him and the
monsters who are lurking just outside
tawguy then snaps her out of it as
six-pack stud calls out glasses guy
firstly our partners down here are the
only ones we can trust but that could be
a problem since we don't know them well
enough heck six-pack stud is a convict
from the start i would have taken into
account how being down here would affect
everybody and this includes stress
levels because this blonde girl just
tried to beat the [ __ ] out of the kid
before she suddenly came to her senses
this makes me think that she's losing it
and if that's the case then how long
before the rest of the group goes crazy
too stress build up can disrupt synapse
regulation resulting in the loss of
sociability and the avoidance of
interaction with others blond-haired
chick going nuts already makes me think
that the longer we stay down here the
more messed up dangerous and unreliable
our group will start to be and i can't
be leading a bunch of crazies down here
so believe it or not i'd break out these
golden hands and start giving everyone a
free massage foot massage back rub and
even maybe a yoga session or two to get
every single person in this room to
chill as the better i help them manage
their stress levels the safer off i'll
be at least until we get to the surface
then it's every man for himself which is
why it would be good to make a few
friends down here six pack stud calls
glasses guy out saying before entering
cryosleep they had to take off all of
their belongings but glasses guy is
still wearing his chain necklace glasses
guy whips up [ __ ] and swears he
snuck his necklace through security but
no one believes him that's when he grabs
his gun and holds kasumi hostage finally
letting the truth out he says that he
planned to come here alone until
everyone followed him claiming that he
was sent here to do god's holy work
shooting the controls on his way out as
he drags kasumi into the lift saying
that if anyone follows him she's dead
before leaving he gives them directions
out of this place as the lift door
closes on kasumi's terrified face in the
lift glasses guy realizes that he's seen
kasumi before almost getting scared
himself at the sight of her but she
doesn't know what the hell he's talking
about back at the security center
six-pack stud prepares to go get kasumi
as he owes her one thanks to her saving
his butt earlier the rest decide to join
in but just then blonde girl suddenly
finds out the most horrifying news on
the computer they find today's date
showing it's only been two days since
they went to sleep not years not months
but two days they quickly leave the
center to find more answers from
glassesguy who surely knows more than
he's letting on back in the lift glasses
guy tells kasumi of when he met her back
when the cryogenic chamber started to
open up he saw kasumi brute force opened
the entrance to the pod bay following
behind her millions of live thorns as if
she was controlling them but kasumi
thinks it's her identical twin sister
shizuku she's alive kasumi begs the doc
for more information about her sister
but that's all he knows she left just as
quickly as she came just then a massive
rumbling is heard as the lift trembles
something is going on outside meanwhile
six-pack stud and the gang come across
an atrium and bump into more of those
terrifying monsters as the hallway and
the floors beneath are littered with
flesh-eating demons so they head upwards
as quietly as they can using the vines
to painfully cling to the ledge the boy
and blonde girl go first then tallgai
follows but a second major tremor
bellows through the atrium as pieces of
glass shards and debris come crashing
down causing the blonde girl to
inadvertently squeal for her life
alerting the monsters below they need to
get out of there six-pack stud prepares
for the inevitable as he gets surrounded
by monsters but takes one for the team
firing around into the gas line causing
the whole area to blow up okay they
could have avoided this hiccup from the
beginning after experiencing what the
kid had to say we now know for a fact
that these monsters use echolocation
they could have used this to their
advantage to have been prepared for what
was to come they were already at the
security center and stocked up on ammo
and weapons they could have foreseen
that they were probably gonna run into
more of those monsters so they should
have stocked up not on just ammunition
but throwable items to distract the
monsters the beauty about this is that
they could have used anything as stuff
that they could have thrown and as they
needed to climb the metal ledge they
could have even used their bullet round
to distract the monsters simply by
tossing one down to the bottom floor of
the atrium right before they needed to
make their break by climbing upward the
sound emitting from the bottom of the
atrium caused by the thrown objects
could have likely led most of them down
there seems like 87 or you're not
subscribed to help us with the algorithm
and subscribe now kasumi wakes up with a
start finding herself still in the now
broken lift with glasses guy seemingly
nowhere to be found she gets up and
enters into a strange green room filled
with horrifying creatures and monsters
suddenly she hears voices and she
quietly goes to the sounds coming from
the far-off room at the end of the
hallway here she overhears glasses guy
confessing to what he did to six-pack
stud saying that he borrowed a dead
man's clothing and snuck in to pretend
to be one of the patients he also claims
that he's planning to upload the entire
database of what went down here into a
memory card just as a loud rumbling is
heard in the distance six-pack stud then
goes to check it out kasumi is shocked
at this news glasses guide then pops up
behind kazumi saying that he used to be
the leader of the r d development team
discovering this virus on corporate dime
and saving the world in the process
which he hoped would have led to a nobel
prize as well as fame he says that it
was thanks to the shady boss who lives
up in the tower that he unknowingly
ended up doing the devil's work and
didn't realize it before it was too late
just then the memory card finishes
uploading and glassesguide gives it to
kazumi telling her to use this to show
the world the horrors the venus
corporation has done here but kasumi
isn't having any of it as she angrily
blames glasses guy for the numerous
deaths and the split up of families that
he caused just as behind her the most
terrifying sight lays waiting for their
conversation to end another monster
demon suddenly the demon lunges at
kazumi and glasses guy pushes her out of
the way telling her to guard the memory
card with her life saying whoever
accesses the knowledge hidden within
medusa wins the game just as his head is
torn apart from his body resulting in a
spewing bloody mess kasumi lays there
petrified just a six-pack stud comes in
like a hero to save her shooting
multiple rounds into the monster demon
with a vengeance they then make a quick
getaway into the hallway kasumi runs for
her life and springs across the gaping
chasm barely making it onto the ledge
nearly falling but is saved thanks to
six-pack stud but it's not over six-pack
stud then hangs her loose over the edge
offering a trade wanting kazumi to hand
over the memory card but kasumi refuses
just then she notices the tattoo on his
arm the same tattoo as the man at the
beginning this pisses off six-pack stud
who decides to quit his negotiation and
pull her back in but he doesn't know
that this mistake will cost him his life
mayday made a g-squad to dom
headquarters we have a problem we
officially know that venus corp was
behind everything and we finally
achieved our mission objective and now
i've made best friends with kasumi yay
which means that it only makes sense
that i kill her she's dead weight
seriously hear me out our main reason
was to find out if venus corp was really
behind the outbreak and now we have the
proof but we're still in the middle of
it and there's still a demon monster
hunting us i would simply award kasumi
with a certified haymaker right to the
face knocking her out sorry and then i'd
shoot her in the head then once dead i'd
use her body as food as a distraction
and this way if we run into the rest of
the gang on the way up we could have
simply lied to them about having killed
kasumi it is a fact that relying on
helping kazumi when we already achieved
our mission objective only slowed us
down and put our lives more at risk than
was necessary six-pack stud shoots
rounds into the oncoming monster demon
but it's no use as this blood craving
creature just doesn't stop forcing
six-pack stud to run before kasumi helps
them out barely escaping with their
lives but this beast refuses to die
forcing six-pack stud to run to the end
of the hallway making his last stand and
beating this beast with a baton crying
out to kasumi to climb up to the ledge
before it's too late but she isn't quick
enough and six-pack stud isn't strong
enough and the monster knocks him down
right next to her cornering them they
are about to die right here right now
until suddenly a beautiful explosion
happens right in front of them lighting
up the monster as it squeals in pain
it's tall guy and blonde girl who have
come to save them and they continuously
light up the demon with molotov
cocktails but kasumi then realizes that
the data chip is gone their only hope of
showing to the world what happened here
is gone the group then reunites and
escapes as the ceiling then collapses
onto the monster they then take refuge
in a cellar as kazumi then outs six-pack
stud telling the gang that he knows more
than he's letting on six pakistan then
reveals that he's a second lieutenant in
the british special forces the sas he's
been undercover and took the post of a
convict for the cryosleep chamber once
he found evidence that venus gate cooked
up medusa as a bioweapon he had orders
to blow the lid off of this castle the
gang acts in disgust as they try to wrap
their head around this terrible news
six-pack stud then tells them that his
plan is to bring in the ceo of venus
gate this russian guy as he's been
exposed to the medusa virus this whole
time but is asymptomatic which means
he's got something in him that they can
use to stop this virus okay i'd be a
little concerned with the uh rumblings
that have been heard throughout our
adventure has anyone else been paying
attention to this because instead of
being below ground in the advanced labs
we are now walking through an old ass
castle which freaks me out a little bit
because i doubt that it's up to code to
withstand a collapse from an earthquake
buildings in general need to be able to
redistribute forces that travel through
them during a seismic event whether that
be in the form of installed sheared
walls cross braces diaphragms or moment
resistant frames to reinforce a building
and i doubt that they thought to install
all of this during the 15th century
which means we need to be on alert as is
not only the monsters that could kill us
but the very structure of this castle
could crush us if we aren't careful now
on another note we lost our only
evidence in the form of that memory card
so that sucks so all we got left is the
ceo of this whole shitstorm and the ceo
may be asymptomatic but that doesn't
mean that he's immune to the virus it
could just mean that his immune system
has only encountered a smaller viral
load or it could mean that he's been
exposed to similar biological entities
before i'm just saying there could be a
million reasons why this ceo hasn't died
yet from allegedly being exposed to the
medusa virus their best bet if they had
to would be to head to the reception
area break into the computer system and
find out where the ceo's office is
located because the contents in his
office could more than likely reveal to
us some more information about the virus
and that was the worst case scenario
just then a rumbling is hurt again and
the doors to the cellar bust open
causing the gang to close it shut but
this time something bumps at it is it a
monster demon nope just that old russian
ceo bastard as he pushes in all withered
and beaten russian guy then looks up at
kasumi's face and gets a terrible fright
he's seen her face before or maybe it
was her sister shizuku russian guy comes
clean saying that a test subject went
out of control and that was the cause of
all of this his mission with this virus
was to take the power of dreams to forge
a new reality but that's when everything
went horribly wrong suddenly flood water
comes rushing in and fills the cellar
quickly russian guy then points them
towards a new way out causing six-pack
stud to blast a new way through as the
russian guy leads the way he then spills
even more beans and tells them eight
years ago a meteor came crashing down
upon a remote siberian village causing
everyone there to die of a remote
disease except for this one girl and it
is here when they met the most
terrifying creature fully formed from
this girl's imagination as if it were
through some kind of magic thanks to
this unknown virus from outer space by
purging the effects of this virus and
bringing this creature to life this
little girl somehow survived medusa and
this led them to believe that creatures
formed by one's dreams from the medusa
virus will never contract the virus
itself and this is what venus corp was
working on but this guy is a russian
psycho and thinks that this virus is a
blessing in disguise meaning humanity
can evolve through dreams into something
much better this was the reason everyone
here was chosen as test subjects to have
their dreams experimented on russian guy
says that after this little girl's death
and during the last two days he came
across a new test subject a little girl
much like kasumi but that's when
everything went horribly wrong kasumi
demands to know who this girl was but
the doctor ignores her and says how he
couldn't bring himself to stop the
experiments and that it's now too late
to fix anything just then a massive
gunshot is heard as six-pack stud
quickly disarms russian guy kasumi has
had enough and demands russian guy to
take her to where this secret girl is
being held captive suddenly vines burst
through the ground in a storm of thorns
and the gang makes a run for it leaving
russian guy to his fate but then
suddenly another monster demon appears
right in front of them the little kid
then quickly runs under the monster's
legs leaving this beast to charge
towards the rest of the gang before
six-pack stud then comes guns blazing
telling them to go find the kid as he
may know the way out holy crap we got
another one of those demons great we
gotta think fast good call on attempting
to protect the kid as he has proven
himself to be a tremendous asset so far
and his gamer skills have certainly
proved their worth and you know the only
person who hasn't done much to help
blonde girl which means she's gotta go i
would have pushed her directly into the
monster's way using her as a distraction
as these beasts tend to be a bit
distracted when chomping on human flesh
if the gang thinks that they hunt
primarily with sound then i would first
aim to destroy that part of their body
first over anything else that would
leave them at least a little bit
discombobulated before escaping as
without their super powered hearing aids
they'll be a little more than a helpless
nuisance and this way we get to save
some ammo just in case six-pack stud
beats the devil out of this demon until
his shotgun breaks then the demon uses
this advantage and grabs his face ending
his life right here and now just kidding
tall guy comes back swinging excalibur
and puts one right in his noggin saving
six-pack stud but not before dying from
the medusa virus himself the rest of the
gang meets a dead end until six-pack
stud joins them and tells them to
quickly dive in before the water gets
them swimming upward to prevent the
current from forcing them back down
ultimately reaching the ladder and
climbing out they don't realize it yet
but almost all of them are about to die
as they get out the group finds a
helicopter a six-pack stud tries to get
it to start meanwhile kasumi finds a
video recorder showing footage of her
sister shizuku being infected with
something horrible causing the medics to
take her into the castle itself shizuku
was inside the building all along kasumi
runs back in towards the castle before
six-pack stud tries to stop her but is
no use the castle then begins rumbling
with the surrounding vines coming to
life going nuts all around them this
girl
she's caused us enough stress and has
single-handedly ruined our mission
objective with the current destruction
of that memory card remember that that's
what happens when we leave her with nice
things she breaks them if shizuku is in
there then that means there must be some
significant reason for this as we
clearly didn't see her getting in the
pods with us and since kasumi and
shizuku are identical twins i say our
best bet would be to kidnap kasumi and
take her with us and allow the world to
study her genetic material now i know
being twins means that one of them could
have picked up genetic mutations growing
up making both of them to be 100 copies
of each other not necessarily a thing
but still i think it's a better idea
than letting her run away at this point
she's our best bet in figuring out what
happened to the world as the ceo of
venus corp is dead and we lost our only
evidence in that memory card which is
actually kind of kasumi's fault too so i
say she owes us one six-pack stud gets
back into the chopper and gets blonde
girl and the kid out of there but at the
last minute he tries to go back for
kazumi but blonde girl sticks a gun at
him and threatens to blow his head off
if he doesn't take her and the kid out
of their asap the castle itself has
morphed into a terrifying vine dragon
roaring with all of its might and it
attempts to fly away with the castle
itself then all of a sudden blonde girl
starts coughing like there's no tomorrow
and accidentally shoots the helicopter
controls in the process six-pack stud
tries his best but is then violently
ejected from his seat flying off as
blonde girl and the kid go down with the
helicopter six-pack stud rolls off of
the roof thinking fast as he falls
through the window and lands right in
front of kasumi herself who has just
found out where her sister is being kept
six-pack stud is distraught about
blond-haired girl and the kid but agrees
to help kasumi for his final mission and
one that will cost him his life six-pack
stud and kasumi head deep into the
castle as they enter a cryo-sleep
chamber but then six-pack stud all of a
sudden sees his sister show up but she's
been dead for years six-pack stud knows
that this is not real and that this is
actually alice the castle's advanced
computer doing all of this she says her
new mission directive is to destroy
anything that affects its newly created
host and fights six-pack stud in a
brutal death match alice then reveals
that petrification aside medusa is a
virus that affects the mind and that
those who contract it fit a certain
psychological build with more than
likely a traumatic past she says that
medusa makes those who contract it
highly fragile with the new optimal host
of this castle becoming unstable if she
lost kasumi meaning that kasumi is the
key to stopping all of this we also cut
back to two days ago when six-pack stud
met up with glasses guy right before
shizuku appears before their very eyes
as a plant monster controlling medusa
herself and she spares glasses guy and
six-pack stud right before kasumi woke
up six-pack stud then realizes that the
only way to stop alice from this
hallucination is to get rid of the chip
in his neck and shoots himself right in
the neck ringing him of the microchip
and barely surviving in the process phew
my goodness there are so many ways that
this could have gone wrong and really
everything should have gone wrong cause
one the trajectory of the bullet
determines the anatomic injury but it's
clear as day that six-pack stud shot
that round right into his neck he didn't
even try to angle it or nothing the
platysma is a broad sheet of muscle
fibers that extend from the collarbone
to the angle of the jaw and serves as an
important superficial landmark as
patients without violation of this layer
are less likely to have injury to deeper
structures within the neck the bullet
also could have had a more erratic
trajectory which makes it all the more
likely that there's no way six-pack stud
could have predicted where the bullet
was gonna end up and even if he did you
don't have to be a doctor to know that a
shot to the neck would at the very least
require immediate medical attention
six-pack stud wakes up to realize that
his sister is actually a vine monster
and blows it to hell he then reaches for
the deactivation code to shut down alice
and the whole operation but is stabbed
through the chest by a vine barely
pressing the button in time and that's
when it all begins the enormous plant
monster then gets affected as it
struggles to maintain its flight
elsewhere kosumi wakes up in a vine
filled room with shizuku laying in the
middle of the room like sleeping beauty
kosumi then tries to go save her but in
a horrible twist sees her sister laying
dead on the table but something is not
right she then realizes that the woman
on the table is not shizuku but kasumi
herself meaning that she is actually
shizuku it turns out that before they
went into the castle kasumi didn't want
to leave shizuku and in an effort to
stay together forever tried to kill
shizuku along with her but failed
resulting in kasumi's death shizuku was
so traumatized that she blocked that
part of her memory and assumed the
identity of her sister kasumi and that
the lady in the recording was shizuku
herself evolving into medusa right after
her sister's death this revelation
causes the medusa hold on her to snap as
her own reality comes crashing down
right before her ultimately defeating
medusa in the process just then six-pack
stud comes crashing in to save her as
they run for their lives to escape the
castle before it's too late forcefully
creating their own exit plan before
shizuku's powers helped them land safely
in the aftermath six-pack stud says to
not give up hope and to keep on living a
soldier's dying wish
just then shishuku runs into the kid as
they reunite and go and search for help
hoping to forget this terrifying place
forever and if you ever want to leave
this terrifyingly sexy video of ours
don't forget to like comment subscribe
and check out how to be playlist down
below